Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
This will be my Full
Secret Invasion Episode 3 video.
There are a whole bunch of Easter Eggs,
a whole bunch of confirmations
about theories
we had who's really been in school
this whole time.
Avengers,
who have been skrulls this whole time.
If you're brand new to the channel.
I'm doing videos for all the episodes,
be sure to subscribe to get them.
We're also doing a giveaway for Disney
plus memberships.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and let me know who
you think has been a skrull
this whole time in the MCU.
Careful for spoilers on the episode.
If you haven't seen it yet,
we'll start at the beginning
and just work our way
through shot by shot.
Talking about Easter eggs
wtf moments in those big skrull reveals,
especially at the end of the episode.
Do starting with the episode
title Betrayed,
which is a reference to that
Avengers character.
Now because I get the spoiler warning.
Rhodey is a skrull.
He's been a skrull for a good long
while now.
The question is
how long he's been a skrull.
It's also meant to be a reference
to Taylor's daughter, Gaia, Emilia
Clarke's character betraying Braddock.
He finds out that she is the traitor
in the group by the end of the episode.
but don't worry.
She's not dead.
Even though he shoots her
and then drives off,
she's still in the rest of the season.
They have big plans for her in the future,
the MCU, she's going to become sort of
like a version of Abigail Brand,
maybe even using that name
from the comics,
even though she still Skrull
really my theory right now is that she'll
just start working with Nick Fury
on his saber space station
as a version of Abigail,
but like kind of using that moniker,
but taking Maria Hills Place where she was
like Nick Fury's right hand person.
now it's probably going to wind up
being Emilia Clarke's character.
it's kind of like what they did
with Kit Harington's
Black Knight
character during the Eternals movie.
Like they sort of established
the character
even though they have more time to do it
with Emilia Clarke's character here.
But they had big plans for Kit Harington's
character in the future of the MCU.
you could also say the title
is a reference to Nick Fury's wife
kind of betraying him in his absence
after Avengers Endgame,
Because at the end of the episode,
the also revealed that she'd secretly been
working with Graviks group and Skrull
Rhodey, who is also on the Graviks team.
To be fair to her
though, I think the idea is that
she wanted to help the rest of her people
like she did before she met Nick Fury,
before they got together as a couple.
that was when she was talking to Nick Fury
about like I turned into the me
I was before I met you,
just another Skrull
that was trying to help her
people survive.
it is the person that she was helping
turned into a radical
and wants to take over the planet.
So she kind of betrayed him, so to speak,
even though I think
based on the trailer footage,
she'll wind up helping Nick Fury.
but then the opening scene is of Graviks
new recruit better
from episode one who just joined the group
getting ready to go out on a mission.
They're trying to start this war
using the submarine,
the nuclear missiles and the U.N.
plane in.
The whole idea is that the rest of
his group is trying to psych him up.
He's not quite
sure about what's happening.
I think that's meant to flow with the idea
that not every single member on grab
group is meant to be evil.
Some of them just want to help
their people
and gravity is taking advantage of them.
They're the ones that impersonate
those military personnel
that tried to launch the missiles
at the end of the episode.
Then gravity checks
on their Super Skrull machine.
We get a better look at it.
You can actually see this
room is exposed to the elements,
but it's inside this larger abandoned
power plant where the rest of the skrulls
have been living.
the rest of the council
come in to check it out in Gravik
explains his new plan to start an all out
World War three,
which they reference later in the episode,
who get the British submarine
to destroy the U.N.
plane, causing the world to slowly
break out into all out war.
In the skrulls
will use that chaos to take over.
but also, he tells the council
about his super Skrull plan
to turn them all into super skrulls
because he's expecting The Avengers
to eventually assemble rally against them.
will need to become super versions
of ourselves superheroes like he literally
says the word super Skrulls.
if you zoom in and
hands on the background of their lab here,
you can see on the wall that they
a timeline of the whiteboard
that shows the stages
of the Super Skrull testing
and how it's meant to progress.
The newspaper clipping on the right that
they've framed is about DNA discoveries,
which is meant to represent the key
to how their group of skrulls
learn how to combine
the DNA of other superpowered
beings with their skrull DNA
and when he says,
they'll be able to change POWERS
That's just part of the Super skrulls
abilities in the comics.
In a bit of what happened
during the comic book version
of Secret Invasion, with him impersonating
different Avengers characters
and being able to impersonate their powers
as well.
Originally in the comics,
the Super Skrull was just one character,
so all the regular skrulls
couldn't impersonate other characters.
Powers They could just make themselves
look like other people.
originally the Super Skrull
was just a Fantastic four character,
given the powers of the Fantastic
Four characters just those four
that's because he came from the Fantastic
Four comics like the Skrull Emperor
at the time, Emperor Dorit created him
to fight the Fantastic Four, specifically,
they featured him in a bunch
of the animated series over the years,
whereas in the MCU, with these versions,
they're getting abilities
from a bunch of different characters
from across the Marvel movies
and Marvel Disney Plus series.
So far we've seen them with Groot, Frost
B's, Cool Obsidian in Extremis powers.
But there could be more Later
in the episode, Gravity also reveals
that he's already got Extremis powers,
like he's already turned himself
into a Super Skrull.
some of you
probably spotted the references here too.
But the way they're doing this, though,
even though they're using different MCU
characters, they're sort of replicating
the powers of the Fantastic Four,
using other MCU characters like route
stretching ability that you see gravity
using is similar to Reed Richards
stretching ability. Cool
Obsidian would be kind of like the powers
of the thing being extremely strong.
Extremis flame abilities would be kind of
like the human torches powers
Normally I wouldn't say frost.
These powers are that much
like invisible woman's powers,
but they might say that
Frost Beast has the ability to camouflage.
so. It seems like it enables the skrulls
to turn invisible when released.
Just them camouflaging themselves.
We'll see how that power works.
We've only seen them use group powers
in extremis powers during the episodes
so far in the trailers.
but this is meant to be confirmation
that gravity plans
on turning all members of their group
into super heroes, giving them all powers
and they'll all have
all these different powers themselves.
It won't just be one power
for each character.
They'll get all the abilities.
to make more Fantastic four references.
They kind of had a version of this
as an Easter egg during Fantastic
Four Rise of the Silver Surfer.
Chris Evans, Human Torch got everyone's
powers briefly, but they use the power
cosmic from the Silver Surfer to explain.
So it's kind of a twist on the idea
of the Super Skrull, but.
Him using everyone's abilities at the same
time was meant to be a Super Skrull.
Easter egg
Speaking
of which, I literally just did a video
about Chris Evans
coming back as his version of Human Torch
from the Fantastic Four movies in Deadpool
three.
cannot wait
to see what that's going to look like,
pretty much anybody who's ever
been in a Fox Marvel
movie has a pretty good chance
of coming back during that.
Even Ben Affleck's daredevil.
but the whole idea is that
with their powers as super skrulls,
they'll just create even more chaos,
causing the humans to all kill each other
so they can just
sort of walk in the rubble,
just move in after everybody's dead,
he wants to get the humans to do the busy
work of killing each other off.
Remember during episode two, he said
he simply doesn't want to rule the humans.
He wants to get rid of all of them
just in general,
because they implied
in last week's episode
that the Skrulls had already
been ruling Planet Earth in secret.
they'd already taken over
many of the world's nations, replacing
key world leaders, key people in power,
and they were just content to live
in that secret invasion environment.
They wanted to keep things status quo.
But that wasn't enough for Gravik.
He wants skrulls to be able to walk around
in broad daylight in their true forms
without having to worry about it.
his big argument with Talos
about how this is going to play out.
Like if you tell the world
about the Skrulls and reveal the truth,
they're not going to side
with the good trolls.
Like they won't see the difference
between our two groups of Skrulls.
They'll try to kill all of us
no matter what.
Then we get another Nick Fury flashback.
We're getting a bunch of Nick
Fury backstory. During this episode.
There are a couple conversations
with a lot of exposition meant to tell you
what Nick Fury was doing
for all these years since the nineties.
this year's
to 1998, one year after that 97 flashback.
In last week's
episode, we're in New York City
and he goes to see Vera,
who isn't his wife yet.
but it seems like
they are in a relationship.
like Vera actually wants to get together
in a more serious way with him
and he's kind of reticent about it.
his reason
for having the meeting with her.
Is it to check in
after her recent mission,
which was to Russia, and to find out
what's going on with the Red Room
in Dreykov,
big Black Widow movie connection,
the also revealed that she just took
this form like this is brand new.
They have a couple of funny moments
like this
when they're talking to each other like,
oh, where did you take this form?
Where did you get this idea?
she does have a ring on her ring finger,
but I'm guessing
it's not their wedding ring
because the way they talk,
it sounds like they haven't
actually gotten married yet.
so. Maybe it's a piece of skrulls jewelry
or just something of personal significance
to her.
It does sound like they've been doing it
on the deal between missions.
But the whole idea is that Nicole is like,
we're still part of shield.
We can't fraternize
with people below our rank.
And he's our commanding officer.
but then they confirmed
that there was no official record
of the skrull
task force Inside Shield ever existing.
it's not like the rest of shield
would find out about the relationship
or what they're doing together.
this is also meant to sort the continuity
to like who knew
that the Skrulls were on planet Earth
and when did they find out?
for the most part,
they want to tell you in present day
that most people in most of the Avengers,
not all the Avengers,
but probably most of the Avengers,
don't know about the Skrulls
that are the big point of contention.
Like, you know,
how could The Avengers, as powerful
as they are, like as smart
as some of them are, as much as they know,
how could they not know about the Skrulls
all explain that in a second
to I think a couple of The Avengers
didn't know about the Skrulls
whenever it mentions
Drake offs, people being on their heels.
She's talking about the Black Widows.
She talks about the Black Widow
program Drake
was the head of the Russian Red Room, ran
the Black Widow program for years.
they explained most of that backstory.
During the Black Widow movie.
The Black Widow
program was how he got started.
And at this point in the nineties,
Natasha and Yelena
Belova will be a little bit older,
but they still be pretty
young girls still having gone
back to the Red Room training program.
In the middle of that
during the Black Widow
movie, their mission to the United States
with Red Guardian and Melina,
where they pretended to be that family,
they kind of became a surrogate family
to each other, ended in 1995.
So this is 1998.
So it was after their mission ended,
they came back to Russia, and both Natasha
and Yelena went back to the Red Room.
based on Natasha's age,
during the Black Widow movie,
she might almost have been activated.
She might have quite
the active at this point is Black Widow.
She might still be in the red room.
The other thing that's going on
in their conversation, too, is
they want to remind you that Fara has been
an agent of SHIELD, so to speak,
to make more agents of shield references.
This whole time.
She has black widow level skills herself
as a special agent.
kind of the way that Hawkeye's wife
was revealed
to be an MCU version of Bobbi Morse
in the Hawkeye series.
so for a long time
she was a regular shield agent
and just as good a fighter
as the rest of them.
it's all in service of Sara
being activated at the end of the episode
when she pulls the gun
out of the safety deposit box,
like she'll actually get involved
with a lot of the action
in the rest of the episodes.
we'll see if they ever wind up doing that
with Hawkeye's wife.
Then we see a news broadcast with Shooter
McGavin, Skrull Council member,
doing his very best J.
Jonah Jameson impression on his news
broadcast,
trying to stoke everyone's fears.
So the general population just in general
will be ready to start the war once
the skrulls set it off Within the Secret
Invasion series in the MCU.
His real name is meant to be Chris
Stern's.
We see the real version of him
at the end of the episode
in one of those skrull devices.
but it's basically what you see here.
He's meant to be kind of like a Jay Jonah
Jameson type of figure, riling
everyone up in the worst possible way.
Like, let me tell you
about how the world is terrible.
Here's the worst thing you've ever heard.
Get pissed off, grab a gun,
go out and shoot a whole bunch of people.
the rules plan is to get everybody
to kill each other off, basically.
So they want people to get as pissed off
as possible in present day.
They have it out together, she says.
It's been years since he's been back.
he calls her Scylla, which is short for
something that actually made me wonder.
Vara was meant to be her name in the past.
So that makes you wonder
if this is some other part of her name.
We're just learning now,
or this person that we're looking at here
is a completely different character
than his wife in the past.
because right after this conversation,
Nick Fury also asks her
who she's become in his absence is both
a metaphor and literal.
Like, how has she changed
since the snap, metaphorically,
during the five year time jump?
that's also a big thing to
they're implying that she was not snapped.
She grieved him for those five years,
as she said, until the hook snap
brought everyone back.
And that's also probably when she started
working with Talos in Graviks group.
like you started working with them again.
It sounds like for a while
she was living as Nick Fury's wife.
doing the regular way through duties. but.
I think they also want you to wonder
if she might have used her powers
during that period
to turn into other people.
Like who are you physically?
Who have you changed into physically
since I last saw you Then she explains
after Avengers Endgame,
she got really pissed off
when Nick Fury took off to a space station
like you just took off again.
So what was I to do? Then?
She started to become more active,
doing the same type of things she did
before she actually got together
with Nick Fury.
Like she's just helping out her
people in general.
that's when she became more active
with Graviks group
then because of the big twist with Skrull
Rhodey at the end of the episode,
I think we can say that
the mystery phone call
that she gets while they're having
that conversation is Skrull.
Rhodey Nick Fury also looks at the phone
like he tried to check out who she calls.
So I think that he's going to figure out
about Skrull.
Rhodey pretty soon too,
because of something
he says later in the episode,
which confirms
a lot of our theories about Skrull. Rhodey
nobody calls
him Nick, And Rhodey called him Nick.
so we think the idea is the already knows
that Rhodey is a skrulls literally.
Later in the episode
he tells Talos that there's a high ranking
member inside the U.S. government
who is a Skrull.
I think he's talking about Rhodey
love is joke about retiring
and then taking up revenge as a hobby
with all his new free time.
Like I think I'll take up revenge.
Obviously talking about stopping Graviks
group taking revenge on those skrulls
this whole conversation.
Gravity has rousting Emilia Clarke's guy
character is because of what happened
last night
with the skull that they had to kill.
He's already suspecting her,
as he does at the end of the episode too.
So if it wasn't clear one of his side
goals in this whole strike against
the U.N.
was to also try and suss out the traitor
who he probably suspected might be her,
but just wasn't sure about it
till the end of the episode.
like he still wanted to start a war, like
he wanted the missile strike on the U.N.
plane to go off.
But he also wanted to use the mission
to find the traitor.
so that's why at the end of the episode,
he says their mission was still successful
because he did
find out who the traitor was,
even though they stopped the missiles.
Gravik and Talos have their parlay.
Meeting is at the British Museum around
a bunch of paintings of important figures
from history, particularly talking
about the painting of statesmen from World
War One.
the Gravik uses as a metaphor
for their two different kinds of skrulls,
like the soldiers in the bureaucrats,
which he's talking about, the council
that he basically just took over recently.
he uses the painting as a metaphor
for his group of arrows,
which, if you like, the soldiers.
We are doing the actual work
of trying to save our people.
And you bureaucrats skrulls
haven't done anything the past 30 years
is another callback to Nick Fury
and Captain Marvel's Broken Promise.
Like saying that Taylor has done
nothing about them breaking their promise.
Like you were just going to let things
continue the way that they were.
they give us a little more backstory
on Skrulls culture just in general.
Like we're using the series to learn
more about
what happens inside the skrulls culture
when they reference an honor meeting,
which is like their version of a duel
to the death.
like a formal challenge that different
skrulls can have with each other.
Throwing the gantlet down.
Gravik reveals that he's replaced
all the people in the museum
with his group of skrulls,
so the Talos can't outright kill him
when he warns Gravik about humans
being at their most formidable
when they're threatened.
Talos is talking about Avengers
Infinity War in Avengers, Endgame
with The Avengers battling Thanos.
Talking about the way The Avengers rallied
in Avengers Endgame after they lost
almost everything to the snap
and then came back to destroy Thanos.
trying to say that something similar
will wind up happening in an all out war
with the Skrulls in this comic book
version of Secret Invasion.
Like if you full on, come for them
eventually, even though you might kill
a bunch of them, they will write like
the new Avengers will come and kill
all of our race.
Talos doesn't want to see the extinction
of his entire race, which is why he says
he's going to reveal to the world
what's really happening with the Skrulls.
The Gravik is the pessimist,
and he's like, No, no, no.
They won't see the difference
between good skrulls and bad schools.
Don't you see the old skrulls are evil
and try to kill our entire race
no matter what?
Some of this dialog I think is also meant
to head off some of the larger questions
that fans will have
as they're watching the series.
Like why don't The Avengers come to help?
They explain that in episode two,
because the skrulls would just
replace them and turn them onto fugitives.
this is also meant to explain why gravity
can't just go out and tell everybody
what's really going on
because nobody will believe him,
they'll just see a skrull and think that
the entire planet is threatened
and try to kill every single Skrull
they can get their hands on.
the trick of him
pulling his hand from the knife,
then healing the wound is also a big
John Wick movie that they borrowed
from the recent movies in him healing
the damage is meant to show you,
Like I said,
that he's already got Extremis
powers, like he's already turned himself
into a Super Skrull.
the interesting thing,
though, you notice is that it still hurts
him, like the act still hurts.
And to cut his hand like that,
even though he heals it
super fast, extremist doesn't erase
the sensation of pain.
It just gives him a wolverine and Deadpool
like healing factor
it works the same way with Wolverine
and Deadpool two.
Both of them still feel pain like a
normal person would when they're wounded.
Wolverine, for instance,
has to mess his hand up really bad
every time he pops his claws.
look, the way his claws exist
next to his forearm here,
they basically have to push their way
through his post,
like they dislocate all of his bones
and then pierce his skin.
So every time he retracts his claws,
his bones heal, the wounds heal.
but it's like every time he wants to pop
his claws is like
someone stabs him over and over.
He just doesn't show it on his face
because he's done it so many times.
There were a couple of jokes like this
during the Deadpool movies, too,
where he's like, I'm incredible pain
right now, but he heals so fast
that he tries to turn into a joke,
like he hides his pain with jokes,
you know, as Talos bumping into the man
next to him on his way out of the meeting,
passing the cell phone
because it was one of his good skrulls,
helping him
like they were bumping each other
with the cell phone
so they could pass information.
then you notice
when Talus is getting English breakfast,
it's meant to be similar
to what Nick Fury cooked for his wife.
like I said earlier when he mentions
the person high up in the U.S.
government, there's a skrull.
He's probably talking about Rhodey
because of the big reveal.
At the end of the episode has bene
Ansonia falls were to use are MI6 agents
to help out with Graviks pending attack
and she says that she's discovered it
listening device renames her our Nick Fury
covering the eye of the tracking device
that he put up with an eyepatch
like his the internal infiltration
that she's referencing
has a picture of Tony Curran here.
It seems like one of the agents
she suspects might be a skrull,
but this makes three different characters
that Tony Curran has played in the MCU,
which I think is a new record.
There are a lot of people that played
two different Marvel characters,
but I think he's one of the first
to actually do three different characters.
before this,
he was also Thor's grandfather,
before we saw him in the flashback
fighting the dark elves in Thor,
the Dark World.
He was king of Asgard before he passed
the throne to his son, Odin.
Then he played Finn in Coolie
during the Daredevil Netflix episodes
when they were on Netflix.
He was just a regular human mobster.
Talos and Nick Fury
have a big argument in their car
ride that they use
for a lot of exposition.
To give you more backstory
on Nick Fury's character,
But Taylor says that funny joke
about not understanding
why humans keep dogs as pets,
but they mostly use that for
set up for Nick Fury's punch line saying
that he's been cleaning up Skrull messes
the tales has been making for the past
30 years.
the messes
he's talking about is covering up
the evidence that the skrulls exist
for the past 30 years
while he's been using them
as his secret agents Inside Shield.
Like I said, they want to tell you
during this series that for the most part,
most people on planet
Earth did not know about the Skrulls.
But I think a couple Avengers
did figure it out over time.
Like Black Widow probably figured out
about the Skrulls Iron Man
is another character who just has access
to so much information.
His like Friday as well as Davos,
so powerful
that he would have had to have figured out
about the skrulls at some point.
even Steve Rogers, Captain America
probably eventually learned
about the skrulls, like he knew about
what happened with Iron Man's father.
Speaking of which, I also think
that old man, Steve Rogers, retired quote
unquote, on to the saber space station
where a lot of the skrulls are working.
So they didn't know everything
about the skrulls before.
He definitely knows now.
Then we get a bunch of new Nick
Fury backstory where Talus basically says
that before the events of the Captain
Marvel movie,
when the skrulls arrived in 1995,
Nick Fury was just a desk jockey.
Nobody of note in had the skrulls
not shown up.
Like had things not gone down the way
they did in the Captain Marvel movie.
Instead of working with Nick Fury,
he would still have stayed behind
that desk
being no one of note
like when Hydra eventually
tried to take over during the Captain
America Winter Soldier movie, Nick
Fury would not have been able to stop them
because he would have been completely
unremarkable.
Taylor's claims that it was his secret
group of Skrull operatives
working for Nick during the nineties
that made him so successful Inside Shield.
it helped him
climb the ranks of the organization.
He did it on the backs of Skrulls
when he says that they gave him
all the dirt
that he used as leverage against assets.
That's also a bit of a callback
to the Marvel movies
like Iron Man one The Post-Credits Scene,
Iron Man two Also Post-Credits scene
in that movie
where you see all the intel that he's
talking to Iron Man about as he's
putting The Avengers together.
The Skrulls collected all that information
for him.
For example,
what's really going on with Macondo here?
Like that was a huge Easter egg
in the early Iron Man movies.
It sounds like
the Skrulls were able to infiltrate
Wakanda and get information about that.
but they're also trying to use
their argument.
Thales is trying to tell Nick Fury
that his life has changed for the better
with the skrulls in it. it.
It's all about Taylor's argument
for coexistence, like he wants humans
to be able to coexist with skrulls
that's also the reason why
Taylor says he didn't accept Graviks
offer of partnership before
because he believes in coexistence
when they break into the British
Commodore's house and they have a standoff
with the boy in the school who's captured
Talos, this is huge confirms big Rhodey
Skrull theory.
Nick Fury says no one calls him Nick.
And in episode two,
Rhodey calls him Nick,
would you think if people
were on the fence at the end of this
episode is meant to be confirmation
that he really is secretly a skrull?
No, no.
I'm sure there'll be more evidence
and clues is beginning
that further episodes in next week's
episode.
We'll get into this a little bit deeper to
but the real question is
when Rhodey was replaced by a skrull
and how long it's been like
since he's been undetected,
I think the idea is that he's
been of school for a long time.
Basically, the longer that Skrulls
have held their forms, the harder
they are to detect.
So if the Avengers like if Vision,
the other Avengers, didn't detect
that he was a Skrull,
is probably been for a long time
if it wasn't clear though
the little kid wasn't a Skrull
but the Skrull that grabbed the cat
impersonating the Commodore isn't
a total dirtbag and did want the kid
to die as collateral damage.
So the idea is that not all of grabbing
straws are totally evil.
The tails are trying to win
him back to his side
unsuccessfully, though Benny
as his daughter, Emilia Clark's character
pulled the code word
from the real Commodores memories.
Remember, they can do that.
Schools can pull memories, absorb memories
from people.
she reveals herself as the traitor
when she takes out the guards
and they detect the phone call
you notice when she enters this room,
though, she passes the real Kristen's
and this is the real British
prime minister
finally the code word in the British
memories seems like rewinding
a massive VCR tape to like
they had a joke about this
during the Captain Marvel movies.
Kind of like finding a needle
in the haystack Imagine a giant hard drive
that you just had to slowly skrull back
through one scene at a time.
in the code word wound up being Zachary
which was the Commodore son's name
then even though it seems like gravity
kills Emilia Clarke like he shoots her,
she's still alive.
Like she just changed into her
skrull form.
This is the first time that we've seen her
in her adult skrull form to don't worry.
She's not dead.
She's featured in a lot of trailer footage
from later episodes end,
they finally make the Rhodey
scrawl reveal, calling Nick Fury's wife,
activating her as an asset, so to speak,
revealing that she's been working
with Graviks group,
pulling a gun from a safety deposit box.
it's meant to be a parallel for Nick Fury
doing the same thing
with his trademark eyepatch,
the gun that's in his tomb.
but this is just meant to confirm
a lot of our suspicions
like Rhodey's been a skrull.
Big question, though.
Let me know in the comments.
How long do you think
that he's been a skrull?
Next week's episode is probably mostly
dedicated to explaining more about what's
really going on with Skrull Rhodey,
and how his wife gets involved
and eventually starts
helping Nick during Talos.
Because in all the trailer footage,
it seems like she's fighting with Gaia.
So we're confirmed that she's on Nick Fury
side and obviously the guy is not dead.
but if it wasn't clear, the implication
in this episode
based on all their conversations
in the big twist
is that she's been working with Graviks
group since Avengers Endgame behind
Nick Fury's back
while he was on the Saber space station.
if you spotted any other Easter eggs
or references in the episode
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
My Episode four trailer video will post
Thursday in my full episode for video.
We'll post next week
after they release it.
there was supposed to be in a soldier
trailer
this past week,
but Twitter got really crazy.
Like Elon Musk
was doing crazy stuff on Twitter.
as soon as they release
that new Asoka trailer,
I'll do a video for the Ahsoka
episodes will be like the next big thing.
Those are in August
and I'll be doing videos
for those every week too,
just like the Mandalorian episodes.
Everyone
click here for my episode for video.
I think the link as soon as I post
that and click here
for all my secret invasion videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.